welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and obi-wan kenobi on disney plus
introduces us to the inquisitors the
imperial death squad of jedi hunters led
by the grand inquisitor including the
third sister riva the fifth brother and
the fourth sister but the real story
behind all of these inquisitors the one
in this series and throughout star wars
canon and the way the emperor used them
to erase the jedi is bloodier than we
realized so in this episode of between
the duels we're gonna take a deeper look
at these inquisitors their backstory
from the other star wars story lines and
the secrets that fifth brother keeps
under that hat the inquisitors or the
inquisitorius were introduced in star
wars rebels as a group of force
sensitive jedi hunters working under
darth vader and emperor palpatine to
hunt down survivors of order 66 and
track down other force-sensitive youths
we actually learn in charles seoul's
darth vader series this project was long
planned palpatine was referring to his
creepy recruitment of force-sensitive
youths in season two of clone wars when
it was better known as project harvester
the natural talent these children
possess is too great to be wasted by the
jedi i foresee an army of forced
talented spies in my service
trained in the dark side to peer into
every corner of the galaxy from afar
and my enemies would be helpless against
such vision and this arc sidious hires
cad bane to kidnap these children until
anakin and ahsoka intervene and free the
kids but palpatine continued to alter
various nanny droids to carry out his
identification of these gifted children
across the galaxy so jumping ahead to
after order 66 palpatine began actively
assembling the inquisitorius from jedi
who were either disaffected from the
order or tortured into submission the
first recruit was a grand inquisitor a
pulan male who actually served as a jedi
temple guard previous to this he was
present for that false persecution of
ahsoka tano and he always had a
particular iron toward librarian jocasta
nu who had denied him access to the jedi
archives we actually meet this grand
inquisitor in season one of rebels
voiced by jason isaacs when he used the
corpse of the jedi luminar unduly to
lure kanan and ezra into a trap now by
the end of that season kanan's able to
defeat the grand inquisitor allowing
himself to fall to his death you have no
idea what you've unleashed here today
there are some things far more
frightening than death
but now the grand inquisitor's deeper
relationship with vader is being
explored in this series and the rivalry
between these two is a delight it was
actually first shown in the 2017 comics
when palpatine allowed these two to
clash without even telling them that
they were on the same side without even
telling vader that the inquisitors even
existed this is back when the
inquisitors were being trained out of a
headquarters based on coruscant called
the works before relocating to the ocean
world of nur where they are in the
obi-wan kenobi series now when vader and
the grand inquisitor first clashed both
of these servants of the emperor thought
that they and only they were the
emperor's number one and that first
impression left the two with a bitter
rivalry honestly if there's anything
this creepy old man loves it's two boys
who both thought they were his favorite
locking sabers as he looks for a window
to sneer do it he loves to sit and watch
so at this point vader is given command
of the inquisitors to teach them in his
ways of cruelty he does this by being
cruel severing their limbs to teach them
the lesson of loss because if our
generation had to learn by getting our
bodies burned to hell on a hot stove
it's how the younger generation must
also learn it now during these early
years joe costa new sneaks back into the
jedi temple to retrieve a hologram
containing a list of force sensitive
kids but like any great librarian she
cannot help or reprimand some snotty
little kid who she said no to so she
jumps down engages the grand inquisitor
in the two fight but vader intervenes
and despite being told by the emperor to
return jocasta to him alive along with
her holocron vader kills jocasta and
crushes the holocron showing how this
guy actually does not want to make
friends he doesn't want the emperor to
make more sid he doesn't want to work
with the inquisitors he wants to work
alone which gives us a bit of context to
how vader now is in this series so along
with the grand inquisitor let's quickly
remind ourselves of the other identified
inquisitors in star wars canon so on
this obi-wan kenobi series we have the
third sister riva whom we're still
getting to know we also have the fifth
brother now the fifth brother along with
the seventh sister will later have huge
roles in season two of rebels
confronting kanan and ezra on malachor
and that arc also shows us the eighth
brother who's an inquisitor tasking with
hunting down maul but when all of these
hunters and fugitives end up in a melee
the inquisitors don't make it out alive
now this series also introduces us to
the fourth sister interesting that we're
now seeing this inquisitor because in
the 2019 return to vader's castle comics
by kevin scott we learned the fourth
sister's armor ends up in the hands of
rebel commander lena graff who used this
armor as a disguise to infiltrate
vader's mustafar castle and free her
lieutenant hud so something's gonna go
down with this fourth sister and that
rebel commander now those 2017 comics
also show us the sixth brother bill
valen who first appeared in the 2016
ahsoka novel by ek johnston the sixth
brother confronted ahsoka on the planet
radha and ahsoka extracted the kyber
crystals from his spinning blade causing
his saber to explode in his face and
kill him and leaving her with those two
white blades that she wields in rebels
and in the mandalorian season two the
2017 comics also first show us the ninth
sister later revealed to have the name
of masana tide a major character in the
game jedi fallen order who ends up
defeated by calcus on kashyyyk falling
out of a high tree nest but her fate
unknown really the main antagonist of
jedi fallen order is the second sister
trilla sugary padawan to seared junda
the game actually allows you to explore
the fortress inquisitorius on ner and
it's here where trailer fails to kill
calcus and for that failure darth vader
executes her another known inquisitor is
the tenth brother prosset dibs who is a
jedi master who previously tried to kill
mace windu and was imprisoned but after
order 66 the tables turn and he is
recruited to join the inquisitorius in
the 2017 run he joins vader and other
inquisitors on a mission to mancala
where they engage the escaped jedi
fugitive pharyn barr who manipulated
some purge strippers to fire a
pon-prosset and kill him and then a few
issues after this we meet two other
inquisitors a male twee-like inquisitor
and a female [ __ ] inquisitor who end
up kidnapping the infant daughter of the
escaped jedi eve coth and afterwards
when they celebrate vader's senses of
camaraderie between these two views it
as weak and phrases the two of them with
the force so they each die on each
other's sabers there has been another
inquisitor over the years who's been
mentioned jurcera who's a deathmarian
who was trained by some unknown female
inquisitor until jacera killed that
master and took her lightsaber but what
is most intriguing about the inquisitor
numbering system is even though we've
only met a scattered disorder few of
them there presumably are other brothers
and sisters filling in that roster maybe
lucasfilm will fill it all in maybe
leave some of the ranks forever a
mystery but with every inquisitor we
meet it is clear that they were brought
up to embrace their inner hatred their
rage their distrust of each other those
two unidentified inquisitors invader
killed had been talking about what vader
would do after all the jedi were found
and killed and indeed that existential
question resides in the hearts of all
inquisitors they are only alive to carry
out the emperor's mission of weeding out
all jedi survivors but once that mission
is accomplished their own expiration is
next as the emperor told vader when he
first unveiled the inquisitorius to him
they may be force sensitive but they are
not safe therefore when the grand
inquisitor lectures us on his anti-jedi
philosophy you gotta imagine he's
directing that partially at his biggest
rivalry within the ranks of the
emperor's mystical arm he's essentially
saying the longer ones serve the jedi
order the closer one was the high jedi
council and toyota and obi-wan kenobi
himself and the more vulnerable they
were to that whole orthodoxy's
corruption so behind the drama unfolding
in these episodes of obi-wan kenobi is a
subtext of bitter rivalry and
survivalist desperation between vader
and this group of hunters i want to
thank you for joining me for episode 3
of this between the duels series next
episode we're going to look at what
other jedi might have survived order 66.
you can follow me on instagram and
twitter at eavos follow new rockstars
subscribe to rockstar some more analysis
of everything you love thanks for
watching bye
[Music]
you